i love the seidman concert oh [ __ ] you
do you [ __ ] love did you see the
tinder man plus the kindle thing is
great i [ __ ] the holiday but even
like
what i love is it like and you do this
very well
is you gamify
your relationships
with your friends and your pleasures so
like i don't even know if you realize
you're doing it it might be so organic
but it's just like okay it's like you
know what i really love busting balls
with my friends what if we could gamify
this okay here's the roast you know what
i like being like uh charming with girls
or it's fun to watch people be charming
with girls oh what if we did a live
tinder version of it and it's like oh
[ __ ]
you don't you're not aware of this no i
mean you do it with like even your
reaction channel is like on some level
it's like oh my god i'm the best at
reacting to things what if there's a
version where i can do this as content
you
you don't realize you do this no
i mean i would imagine what yeah this
isn't i just no i just do it
you're you're japanese bro
dude have you been to japan uh yeah you
know how they like they they commodify
everything right it's like like i wanna
i want to take a nap with somebody but i
i i don't have time to go home from work
all the way so i'll go to a nap pod i
want a pet an armadillo so i'll have she
do so they figure out and they like
create the content
it's so organic to you you probably
don't even realize you're doing it but
like it's it's masterful dude i'll be
honest with you i'm not trying to stroke
you i mean
i'm being dead serious it's like you
found a way to like
take the organic interactions you have
with your friends and your online
community and then turn it into
structured content
uh
well i guess what with like 20 versus
one as in like there's 20 girls one
creator and we go oh okay we tell you
what to do what to say during these
dates et cetera
but even the tinder thing is great even
though yeah there's a what it's fun to
watch dude even but
for us
we were like oh it'd be funny to do
tinder in real life because we're just
awkward guys but we don't know how to
talk to women but where does that come
from does it come from being at the bar
i imagine with your friends like yo go
up and talk to that girl and then you
say some wild thing and the girl like
turned
yeah
i i feel like you're [ __ ] with me
right now no i'm on this bro honestly
like so you just mistakenly do it right
every time no are you an [ __ ]
no i just i just do
that's crazy i just do
yeah like all like most of my life i've
just done yeah and just like a phone
[ __ ] at the wall see what sticks and
then yeah i kind of just do what i enjoy
as well and yeah i guess yeah like my
life is just this journey of me i don't
want to throw you off because you have
an instinct for it but like
i think a lot of times people are like
let me just film the thing that i do and
it seems as if you guys and i'm sure you
have a team that they have credit too
obviously but like
you're like how do i create these like
structures and games around it
and that's when you turn something from
like just hanging out or a combo into
like a show that can even exist without
you
right it's like yeah
oh my god yeah
yeah yeah tinder could some you could
take that ip and you could put it
somewhere else
ah
i do think you're [ __ ] with me right
now no no no no no no
i just started liking alex wassabi all
the time
no bro like
i don't know i i guess for like us
especially we don't really think like
that we were kind of just we're just
there like aye what's the next video
yeah uh i guess we could do old reliable
hide and seek where we just go and find
a an abandoned place
or and just try and hide and seek simple
as that yeah and just trying to find
each other don't do that one ever again
that's not your strongest
okay
we have like a holiday one where yeah
it's like the cheapest holiday and then
the most expensive and then there's two
teams and then it's kind of like oh
who's going to be the guy yeah or we
would team with the kitten bad team and
then you see both sides what's the worst
concept you guys have come up with for
assignment video there was i think we
just heard it
oh it's old people love it man i think
what you guys have is like organic and
real it feels as if you guys have known
each other before what we have that's
why yeah we've we've just no known each
other you can't take it like yeah yeah i
think a lot of people have tried to like
to create it but it's like if you don't
know someone since you're a kid you
can't like talk about their mom yeah
yeah yeah and when you do you can and
it's like you're safe you don't feel
like you're embarrassed by this [ __ ]
that you just like put into a band
together with
it's uh there's a there's a group in in
america the um
they're not a group what are the the
prank guys what the [ __ ] i can't
practical joke impractical jokers yes
and um and and they were friends before
they did anything okay and you could see
it it's [ __ ] authentic it's real it
just comes out you know i think that's
why like with the simon's growth it's
all just been gradual as well it's not
been like a boom like we're all super
famous now it's kind of just been this
gradual thing like i was just playing
gta and then eventually we just like
stopped and then
we didn't really do anything for viewers
had a few charity football matches
or soccer matches yeah and then uh
beefed right we had a little beef but it
was it was meant to be like
fake and then it turned real
so i was i was leaving the sidemen and i
went to l.a and i kind of was like oh i
want to like switch things up i want to
like change a few things so i went out
with like phase and that that group and
um then i was like oh you know
everyone's doing diss tracks i should do
a diss track on ethan and be like he's
the reason why i'm leaving seidman blah
blah blah but then harry who's uh also
part of the simon just took it to
another level and just started go in on
me just like
like standing on my lamborghini while um
i was in america
and just pissing me off also i messaged
him like and we have a group chat i
think he's in on skype i messaged him
like what the [ __ ] are you doing bro
like this isn't part of the plan like
yeah why are you getting involved with
this and he was just like bro i was just
it was just funny in it i'm like no and
then i was like all right calm and then
i was i was like i need a beat found a
beat and i that's where i wrote little
boy and i just went not bro i was
cussing out his mum his dad
yeah yeah it's all worked out what'd you
say about his mom
you bro if you
[Music]
yeah
it's funny like um that
it was meant to be fake and it's turned
real is that what happened with logan
cause the first thing i saw logan it was
a warrior fight and he was like yeah i
kind of started like a playful beef but
now i like really
hate that yeah yeah so like for me like
for me to like i don't know like i kind
of just
felt like
i don't whenever i'm boxing or training
or anything i'm in this mode of like
[ __ ] that guy i don't give a [ __ ] who
you are i'm taking you out whether you
know anyone likes or not like people
think i'm being mean don't give a [ __ ]
i'm annihilating i'm in warrior mode so
like that's my focus and then with logan
i was like i hate this guy i'll give a
[ __ ] and i'm just gonna take the piss
out of him get in his head and just once
i'm in that ring [ __ ] him up and move on
to the next person so obviously i tried
fighting jake first because i was like
oh jake if i fight jake then logan it'd
be a bigger you know smaller fighter
than bigger fighter
and then that's it but uh jake just
didn't want any of it he was just like
really find my little brother
he had like little jake or something
like that yeah bro he pussied out hard
so that's why i find it hilarious that
when as soon as i go into music he said
like oh where you up [ __ ]
okay is there anything about jake that
you respect is there anything that you
admire i respect bro i respect any man
that goes into the ring yeah because
[ __ ] me bo like that is one of those
really hardest things to do like even
the journey to get to the ring is
[ __ ]
hard bro because yeah look anyone can
get into the ring get knocked out that's
it all right but to be able to do that
journey yeah to then get into the ring
bro it's hard bro it's tough and
i have to respect it [ __ ] him
but i have to respect it yeah yeah yeah
yeah so yeah no there's obviously gonna
be respect there i respect every man
that gets in the ring yeah that's why i
don't respect alex's army bro he's a
[ __ ] [ __ ] bro didn't even get to the
[ __ ] ring i knew the feeling this was
gonna happen yeah yeah bro i felt it bro
i knew as soon as i put too much footage
i was like wow maybe if the music the
music video is a bit too much i'm
showing too much content here yeah and
bro as soon as i release the music video
i get a message from my manager he's
pulled up bro i'm like man
this [ __ ] man
this guy yeah but if you're doing a
tune-up fight that's the risk you're
doing you're kind of fighting a guy to
knock the rust off by knocking him out
so the risk is i'm gonna go fight the
guy that knows he's gonna beat the [ __ ]
out of me what's in it for me really
well first of all like you could tune up
against me i'll never fight you yeah but
i mean i mean he was gonna get a bag
like he was getting money bro like i
won't say i can't say how much it's
contract in it you can't say much
contraction say an amount that's one
million more
it's a decent amount but
150 it's wrong stop trying to get out of
me wait is it is it fifty thousand well
i'm not going to say it fifty thousand
no
no how many primes could we buy with
that
hundred thousand how many jay paul
pay-per-views can we buy
well we can't say it all no no would it
would it be in the millions
so yeah he's getting a certain amount of
money
[Laughter]
and legit
well i was like all right cool like he's
blessed and he's there thinking yeah i
believe i can be ksi yeah get to my way
he thought this guy is so stupid man he
thought if i
went down to his weight i would lose my
power and i'd be
less good and i'm like bro this is my
optimal weight yeah you were stupid you
don't lose weight
fights with logan yeah well i've had to
move up weight i had to eat to get to
his weight this is me being 200 pounds
all this and that that's not my natural
weight yeah my natural weight is in the
185 180 etc like this is optimal this is
me like prime
yeah
and
so like that's what i was like this guy
doesn't know what he's on about he
doesn't know what he's
prepared for anything i know even with
the back and forth i'll say
he's not ready yeah i'm going in on him
he's just quiet like
well i think i think i'm gonna do pretty
well yeah i think i'm gonna beat you up
bro i'm like oh yeah okay buddy
yeah you you need somebody to let loose
in the promo yeah yeah yeah so and that
is why i am gonna be fine swarms
i'm giving you another exclusive right
there wait wait wait wait wait hold on
so that you are gonna have a fight
what is swarms so swoons this is crazy
this is crazy i'm about to find out who
swarms is